um
this
hey help me
wait we need help she's been wounded
what's wrong with her well she's not
whatever the hell's going on out there
she's been stabbed
oh okay listen now brian if we don't get
her to a hospital
she's going to die there are no more
hospitals
oh come on no more hospitals you got uh
doctors you got tree eyes you got a mass
unit
oh look i'm just a grad student okay i i
got volunteers with this i'm
supposed to be out here
okay [ __ ] but
i've only got room for two of you okay
two room for two
we're overweight okay i can only take
two of you two
come on help me come on
all right sweetheart that's okay
you're gonna be all right oh my god i'm
gonna be right back
okay boozer let's go we gotta get on
that we gotta get on that [ __ ] i heard
what he said
there's only room for two in that
chopper
[Music]
go go with her
i'll be okay i'll commit to worshipping
this before
you know
there we go
where are you going what where where
refugee camp west of three finger jack
no cruiser is never gonna make it
without me
i want this back
you're coming
no
[Music]
dick
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what did you do
[Music]
we lost him you can't be far wait hold
on cut your engine
[ __ ] she's alive alvarez
alvarez hey alvarez what happened here
i mean who did this was it was it
rippers
this
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like that yeah
hold up
cover me right behind you
[Music]
he went that way come on
where the hell is he going there's a
[ __ ] out here but a bunch of freaks
maybe i was wrong about him having a
deal with copeland
no leon's been fencing [ __ ] to kotlin
for a long time finally caught up with
him
hey hey wait wait hold up hold up
[ __ ] all right let me see
wait wait wait here down this way
tracks are fresh
so where the hell did you learn to track
[ __ ] anyway i used to go elk hunting
with my old man when i was a kid
ended up tracking [ __ ] for miles
oh [ __ ] get down
come on
you okay brother yeah yeah yeah just a
graze
son of a [ __ ] can't aim worth damn
son of a [ __ ] i'm fine boozer
he must be heading down there toward the
falls he's losing a lot of blood
he's not getting fart come on
search him
bleeding out that's a hell of a way to
go it's slow
a lot of pain but i suppose you know
about that she was still breathing when
we found her you piece of [ __ ] i wasn't
gonna waste to pull it not on her
oh hold on for a second i'm number
second now where's the stash
leon if you tell us
unlike you i can promise you we'll make
it quick
don't look like you'd be suffering for
too long leon
you got a little problem here see they
can smell your blood
from all the way down there what do you
suppose that feels like
torn apart alive
i guess he's going to find out [ __ ] you
goodbye
no wait all right all right
i got it right here take it
where in the cemetery in the old
cemetery
thank you no you said
do it
don't leave me out here man
[Music]
do it do it
you goddamn liar
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's gonna need something for the
bounty
you do the right thing bro we don't want
to leave anyone to the freaks
not even a piece of [ __ ] like leon
hey hold up i want to search this camp
see if i can't find something to fix up
this crash
i just gotta put them together and yes
there yeah that'll do it i guess i won't
be
losing the arm anytime soon
oh we were going hunting tonight take
some bounties in the tucker
well not if it's pissing down rain ah
man we need the camp credits gotta stock
up on supplies
yeah okay i don't want to be out all
night though
jesus i gotta get in shape
i'm gonna see if there's anything we can
salvage on leon's bike
son of a [ __ ] guessing that's the fuel
line unless you just piss yourself
fuel pump yeah yeah shout out my damn
fuel pump
can we get anything off leon's bike nah
it's done
look let's just go back to o'leary
mountain we'll head out in the morning
find some parts and come back and get
your bike
no i think i got a better idea we just
get it while we're out here
what well yeah
crazy willy's isn't far from here let's
just head over there
what are you thinking we were going out
hunting tonight anyway
crazy willy's as good a place as any
yeah
okay
hey what did leon give you a map of some
kind
once we get my bike back let's head up
to the cemetery look around
yeah okay
so tomorrow get the drugs take them to
tucker
collect all leon's bounty then i say we
head north
you think shit's any different up north
don't matter i think you'd do us good
get the hell away from here
hold on something's blocking the road
careful
i saw a setup like this a couple days
ago a bunch of rippers
blocked the road with an old truck come
on help me move it
ready yep
[Applause]
first
[Music]
keep working again
[Music]
come on we're almost there
[Music]
coming up on the old nero checkpoint
we're almost there
[Music]
[ __ ] how you want to do this
blow me your shotgun i'll walk point
looks like that checkpoint had him
backed up pretty good yeah a lot of good
it did him
i'd rather be buried back with the
goddamn pioneers yeah
[ __ ] look at them all bunch of goddamn
dumbasses a lot of them
were they thinking hey mr fed can we sit
here and wait till the goddamn horde
comes through and just kills us all
bad way to go out trapped in a [ __ ] hole
like this
you smell that ah jesus
there come on let's go
hey hold up how many mile times you got
left back here let's hit it on the way
back leave it yeah
leaving my ass son of a [ __ ] you're
hoping someone's home
sounds like you've got a wish
i think it's dead
you're gonna break my shotgun
[Music]
yeah okay
you're going up there again what are you
talking about
goddamn refugee camp you only act like
this when you're thinking about going up
there
act like what it's not your fault
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're not getting your bike through
there try that service tunnel
see if you can clear us a path from the
other side i got it
just keep your headlight pointed that
way
how the hell
i didn't plan on this goddammit
[Applause]
cut it out
another nest
yeah i smell it oh how many molotovs you
got left
whoa you just used the last one
you got any [ __ ] to make more yeah yeah
this will just take a sec
that'll do it ready
[ __ ] here they come
hey come on get on yeah okay give me a
sec
i've been thinking about what you said
about riding north
just saying you need to get away from
here clear your head you know
in the morning let's turn in the
bounties and we'll hit the road
oh yeah brother now you're talking
[Music]
wanted a freak show
[ __ ] place is crawling
[Applause]
[ __ ] we're gonna need more ammo what are
you thinking
and i already know it's a bad idea you
just
ride on through you pull as many of them
off as you can
and i just i going through the back down
that hill find the garage
[ __ ] you just give me a few minutes to
find the part that i need you right back
we ride the hell out
after i kill a few of the bastards i
swear to god you got a death wish
like i said not tonight
go on get out of here you little shits
[Music]
yeah that's right stay up there and
we'll get along just fine
all right
[Applause]
hmm
dick how's it going brother you ready
not yet still gotta find a way in the
willy's garage gotta be a fuel pump
inside
your ass up i wrote past one of those uh
what the hell do you call him the [ __ ]
that rippers put up
sigils yeah it means they're up here
somewhere
roof
[Applause]
yeah that's what i thought
that's it
to be a fuel pump in here somewhere
booser hey there i found the part i'm
heading out to the highway
rippers
ah [ __ ]
rippers boozer booze man
[Music]
hang on lose man i'm coming
get off me
these cats are dead symbols of a dead
man
dead symbols of the loss
get off me the [ __ ]
spiderman you must be brought low by
command
for you are lost
we will show you if you
are not one of the bounds you are the
last
[Music]
these cats are dead symbols of a dead
bat over here
i'm going to kill them all [ __ ]
oh my god oh [ __ ] let me help you up
get up [ __ ] rippers
it's like they were waiting for me or
something [ __ ] ah
how did you see
get on the bike
[Music]
[Applause]
you